[Music]
when it comes to these two games hard
not to compare but in reality these are
two very different looter shooter titles
we at new gaming network have enjoyed
thousands of hours in both of these
games and in this video show the
strengths and weaknesses of both as
mentioned in previous videos gunplay is
what defines destiny few games have a
consistency and smoothness that destiny
offers having a successful engine like
halo to take learnings from has meant
more focus can be put into the
development of other areas of the game
halo and destiny has set the benchmark
for gunplay in the first-person shooter
genre as a third-person shooter the
division has an entirely different field
initially it feels very clunky when
compared to business but after playing
through a few of the missions that
actually makes sense
the division has a more serious
simulation covered based style of play
which matches the more serious
real-world story there are certainly a
number of bugs and visual glitches that
still need to be worked out but the more
strategic style of gunplay certainly
fits in with the overall feel of the
game if Sony has received a lot of bad
feedback over the years because of the
way they had or hadn't included the
story with them again the cutscenes the
church casual players confused as very
little was explained and in some
situations it seems like the developers
just couldn't be bothered explaining for
those who are committed enough the story
goes into fantastic depth but this can
only be found on the bungee website
through the cars of the selected while
playing through the game destiny to look
promising with what the developers are
aiming to achieve but we won't know
until d2 is released in a little over a
month there is a certain amount of
realism to the division story and for
this reason it's hard not to get engaged
sit in Manhattan New York after a
smallpox outbreak which was free through
the handling of money on one of the
busiest days of the year though there
are a number of questions left
unanswered
this is likely done on purpose to help
drive the hype for the future of the
franchise it's also worth noting that
Ubisoft is currently working on the
development of an action movie starring
Jake Gyllenhaal based on the division
story
this is where the games start to move in
different directions destiny has three
classes to choose from hunter warlock
and Titan within each class options are
quite minimal with each class
essentially having the same options to
choose from gear pieces really only have
a few options based around whether you
want to focus on release your name or
supers but this only concentrate from
the frequency that each of these can be
used the weapons have a few more options
and perks that are available but based
on what this in YouTube beta had to
offer
it looks like fun G's planning on
keeping the build customization down to
a minimum
although considerably more complicated
to learn the division build
customization has a lot of depth all
gear and wizard pieces drop with the
possibility of a large number of
different curve these suits can change
pretty dramatically allowing players to
build sit best suited to the situation
on top of this weapons in gear have
modifiers that can be added again these
drop with a large number of possible
perk combinations many hours can be
spent on justice aspect of the game
crafting and hunting for the best pieces
for the build you're trying to achieve
because of the number of possible
combinations there is no identical build
in the division abilities and schools
have been a target of a ton of nerf and
redevelopment much like the weapons in
gear
there is a large number of possibilities
and options available and because of
this there is a constant need for
rebalancing the division has received a
lot of criticism over the in-game
balance one of the greatest parts of
destiny is a huge number of options
available for dressing up your character
gear pieces and shaders and even
Halloween masks this could be due to the
fact that diversity between each piece
is low but regardless destiny does a
great job helping the player feel unique
the way their character looks because of
the realistic look and feel to the game
it does make sense
the divisions vanity build options are
quite minimal there is an antelope ton
of clothing that can be acquired
but generally speaking most outfits look
very similar there are weapon skins that
are available but these will only change
the appearance of your wishes
[Music]
both games had a rough start when it
comes to the loot system but these days
they feel a lot more balanced with
really only one or two noticeable
differences destiny rewards players well
based on the type of game activity
completed certain weapons can only be
acquired by completing certain quests
and tougher in-game content or reward
players with exclusive gear the only
thing that could change is that exotic
items just don't feel very exotic items
like tears coins has made them too easy
to obtain the division community
complained that gives to difficult to
acquire the developers responded with
adjustments to the drop rate and
fortunately this main gear far - eat it
again in-game activities without
unrewarding and players lost the need to
grind this brings us to about a year
after release destiny had a bit of a
lull where new content head right up and
the in-game activities just went there
two years on and there is a ton of stuff
to do with each weekly refresh once
you've finished the raid in nightfall
story missions and strikes can order
Chester often contain explosive energy
items to flash up your character also
available is the challenge of the elders
and rotating crucible types after almost
a year and a half the division has found
itself in the same lull although there
are few activities to choose from like
incursion survival and underground the
fact that items weapons have been so
easy to acquire has meant that hardcore
and easy casual core players who have
been playing since day one have lost the
need to keep grinding for Gear Destiny's
PvP the crucible is packed full of
different game modes like clash crumbled
control and skirmish on top of us each
of the game modes are also available
with modifiers like doubles or mayhem
which can mix up the gameplay in a huge
way the game modes rotate each week
which forces the player into trying new
challenges for the more hardcore PvP
players there is a trials of Osiris this
is a competitive multiplayer mode
reclaim teams of three to earn a number
of games in a row in order to win
exclusive gear and weapons these days
Destiny's PvP feels fast-paced somewhat
strategic and surprisingly balanced
considering the number of different wish
and types available the division as a
dedicated PvP mode lasts and quite late
in the piece again considering a huge
number of build options available the
PvP feels quite balanced although quite
enjoyable and
all over juice there is only one
game-mode capture domination however
this isn't the biggest problem PvP in
the division just feels weird the time
to kill is very high so high in fact
that players can choose to turn and run
in the middle of a fight with no
consequences at all and be near
impossible to kill rather than utilizing
the cover shooter mechanic that is
necessary in PvE you're more often than
not find yourself running around in
circles shooting at the enemy player
from point-blank constantly commander
rolling and firing off heals and then
there's the dark zone players brave
enough to enter this unique area of the
map will be faced with high level enemy
AI that will provide the highest level
of loot drops however competing for the
slope drop is up to 24 other players
players can choose to join an assist
tube or turn on you and steal your loot
this game-mode has been met with mixed
emotions from the community with destiny
too on the horizon the content drops
into destiny won or about to dry up in
evitable II this will mean that the
player base will start to disappear and
at this stage we don't fully know what
to expect from destiny to the division
is in a pretty stagnant place right now
with each update only adding more bugs
to the game the majority of updates
coming out only seem to be focusing on
fixes both of these games are very
different with one being a fantasy
action arcade style first-person shooter
based around a superhuman guardian of
the planet and the other is a more
serious cover based third-person shooter
focused around a division agent in a
real world city crisis because of this
really is quite a challenge when
deciding on which game is best both have
their pros and cons but it really does
come down to the style of game you
prefer if you're more focused on a PvP
fast-paced easy to pick up game play
with a character that can make you feel
like a superhero the destiny is your
game however if you feel more like some
coordinated PvE with more complicated
but greater depth and the customization
options of your secret agent then the
division might be better for you let us
know in the comments below which game is
your favorite here at new gaming Network
were heavily addicted to both and as
long as they're both releasing content
we'll keep investing considerable
amounts of time into them
hey guys hey guys this song mmm is good
news
[Music]
hi guys this is my kitty this is AJ I'm
will dis judge and if you like that
video give it a like or subscribe
who's